ولكن هذه مأساة نحن
الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية
متواطئون فيها في الكثير مما
يحدث من
قصف وأعمال أخرى
نشهدها الآن يحدث
معنا الآن أسلحة
ومعدات بمعنى آخر شئنا
أم أبينا  ليست الولايات المتحدة متواطئة
في الكابوس الذي يعيشه ملايين
الفلسطينيين الآن
السيد الرئيس
ذكرت صحيفة وول ستريت جورنال في الأول من كانون الأول (ديسمبر)
أن الولايات المتحدة قدمت ما لا يقل عن 15 ألف
قنبلة و57 ألف قذيفة مدفعية إلى
إسرائيل، بما في ذلك أكثر من 5400
قنبلة ضخمة تزن 2000 رطل والتي تم تدميرها.  يمكن أن تسوي
أحياء بأكملها بالأرض. وذكرت صحيفة واشنطن بوست
أنه في غضون 6 أسابيع فقط بعد
7 أكتوبر/تشرين الأول، أسقطت إسرائيل أكثر من
22 ألف قنبلة أمريكية الصنع على غزة، و22 ألف قنبلة
أمريكية،
وذكرت شبكة سي إن إن أن ما يقرب من نصف هذه القنابل
كانت غير موجهة مما يسمى
بالقنابل الغبية، لذا سيدي الرئيس، هذا هو  حيث
نجد أنفسنا في هذه
اللحظة، 24.000 فلسطيني في غزة قد
قتلوا، 70% منهم نساء وأطفال، و
60.000
جريح، 70% من المساكن قد
تضررت أو دمرت، وما يقرب من 2
مليون شخص يحاولون البقاء على قيد الحياة
مع إمدادات غير كافية من المياه الغذائية.
الدواء أو
الوقود والوضع الإنساني يزداد
سوءًا في
اللحظة التي يواجه فيها مئات الآلاف من
الأطفال الجميلين
المجاعة، سيدي الرئيس، نظرًا لحجم
الدمار والاستخدام المكثف
للمعدات العسكرية للأسلحة الأمريكية في
هذه الحملة، يجب على الكونجرس أن يتحرك، وهذا
هو السبب  يجب علينا تمرير هذا القرار رقم 502ب،
ويجب علينا التأكد من أن مساعداتنا يتم استخدامها
وفقًا لحقوق الإنسان الدولية
وقوانيننا. سيدي الرئيس، التصويت على هذا
القرار هو ببساطة طلب مزيد من
المعلومات حول الوضع المأساوي الذي
يهتم به الشعب الأمريكي.
الصفحة الرئيسية أقول لزملائي الولاية الحمراء الولاية الزرقاء الولاية
الأرجوانية هذه القضية هذه
المعاناة تدور في أذهان
الشعب الأمريكي وهذا كل ما في هذا
التعديل هذا القرار الذي يصوت الآن
ضد هذا
القرار الذي أجد صعوبة في
فهمه حقًا.  اقتباس
لا أريد المزيد من المعلومات
سأصوت ضد هذا القرار لا
أريد تقريرا من وزارة الخارجية لا أعرف
لا أريد أن أعرف كيف
يتم استخدام المساعدات العسكرية الأمريكية في إسرائيل
لا أريد أن أعرف ما هي المسؤولية التي
قد تتحملها الولايات المتحدة تجاه هذه
الكارثة الإنسانية أريد أن أبقي رأسي في
الرمال لا أريد أن أرى ما يحدث
وبصراحة سيدي الرئيس بغض النظر عن
وجهة نظرك بشأن هذه الحرب الرهيبة  كن
متفقا معي، إذا كنت لا تتفق معي، لا يمكننا أن
ندفن أعيننا في
الرمال